c'est de 1929 à 1947 que joséphine baker
a vécu dans cette demeure pour les
journées européennes du patrimoine la
villa beauchesne a ouvert ses portes ou
plutôt son extérieur des visites
commentées du parc et est organisée par
les membres de la société d'histoire du
vésinet c'est en 29 t ayant commencé à
avoir une certaine notoriété et certains
revenus elle a pu avec son mari de
l'époque acheté cette maison c'est
quelqu'un qui est venu habiter ici pour
être tranquille tant qu'elle vivait au
milieu de ces animaux
un spectacle musical a eu lieu dans la
cour de la villa les visiteurs présents
ont pu également voir l'exposition
consacrée à la vie de joséphine baker
récemment j'ai lu un livre de raconter
sa vie donc j'ai découvert cette femme
que je connaissais très peu en fait et
voilà qu'on habite pas loin mais c'était
l'occasion de voir là où elle a vécu un
moment de sa vie c'est très bien c'est
super bien fait les guides sont gentils
en savent beaucoup donc c'est c'est
agréable dans un cadre superbe
grâce à la notoriété de cette danseuse
et meneuse de revue la ville du vésinet
bénéficie d'une attractivité culturelle
la célèbre artiste est souvent mis à
l'honneur elle est mise en avant nous
lui avons donné le nom son nom sur une
salle associative
nous avons prévu aussi de donner une
option sur une place dans un des
nouveaux quartiers et que nous sommes en
train de construire durant la seconde
guerre mondiale joséphine baker s'engage
dans la résistance c'est donc grâce à
son service rendu pour la nation qu'elle
entrera en panthéon le 30 novembre
prochain ce sera la première habitants
du vésinet à être pente est honni zay
[Musique]
oh